hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video hat mir gedacht ich spiele heute
wieder mal nach sehr langer zeit
das ist ein spiel wo wir uns entscheiden
müssen zwischen zwei sachen also
eigentlich recht simpel wenn wir es hier
zunächst mal die auswahlmöglichkeiten
internet also einmal okay ich habe ein
jahr lang keine zähne oder ich verzichte
ein jahr lang auf das internet was eine
komplette halle sein würde ich mal muss
ich das ganze mal logisch überlegen auf
der einen seite verdiene ich mein geld
mit internet auf der anderen seite esse
ich mein essen mit 10
ich sag mal ich will ein jahr auf das
internet verzichten und binde der
mehrheit man übrigens wieder so wenn ich
in der minderheit bin dann klatsche ich
mir eine wieder so komplett innovativ
diese challenge hätte ich lieber ein
lichtschwert oder würde wissen wie ich
die macht kontrollieren sowie darth
vader oder so ich würde lieber die macht
kontrollieren auf jeden fall mein gott
ich bin eine mehrheit von freundlichem
also das ist total easy eigentlich als
der schwede das halt so ekelhaft
entweder ich trinke eine komplette
gallone voll mit senf was ist eine
gallone ist das ein liter oder so auf
jeden fall muss sich entweder eine
riesige menge an senf trinken oder ich
benutze sind für drei wochen als meine
zahnpasta ich glaube ich würde das
direkt instant trinken ein paar sekunden
später ich bin in der minderheit
also auf jeden fall 21 mann 82 prozent
sagen dass auch ich mein zehn jahre alt
seien es irgendwie cool weil man sich um
nichts kümmern muss sondern die eltern
hat und vielleicht die ganze zeit und
stellen kann und grundschule und so aber
man muss man überlegen wenn wir die
ganze szene ist und nur man selbst dann
wenn sie die eltern tot und dann ist man
nur noch 10 und kann nichts machen die
vier hektar bietet world with other and
ceo of spanish was heißt das alles
natürlich um alle youtuber würden jetzt
irgendwie zwischen die katz gucken
google das wort mal aber ich suche mir
einfach irgendwas aus ene mene miste
apple denn der tc ene mene meck und
gebäck okay ich nehme die spanischen
what you'll have gravity shot of the day
with every one around insane want to
kill you sollte mich jeder töten also
schon fall der dinge weil der dinge weil
der dinge ich würde auf jeden fall eher
sagen dass die schwerkraft für einen tag
ausgestellt werden soll ich bin mit 89
in der mehrheit freunde ganz simple
frage eher kommunismus oder kapitalismus
ich würde sagen er kommunismus was also
mal ganz kurze erklärung ich bin kein
geschichtslehrer oder so aber so wie ich
jetzt erstmal kommunismus verstehe ist
es so gleiches recht für alle so alles
gehört irgendwie jeden aber es ist halt
einfach nicht umsetzbar weil es nicht
geht berichte ich mich bitte wenn ich da
falsch liege aber das ist so das was ich
gedacht habe und dafür welch gewesen if
you could read write history with you
there is no such thing as musik oder der
us nutzer des art lieber keine kunst 80
prozent ich muss mir noch schlagen wegen
vorhin warum hab ich mich dreimal
geschlagen
tirana wir professional taser test dior
bier professional bienbeck galt es die
auf jeden fall taser test in der
minderheit was ist denn los mit den
menschen hier vielleicht sollte ich mal
die bank gewechselt irgendwann wird er
in the world series of windows super
bowl auf jeden fall super bowl weil der
viel mehr leute zugucken wenn ich auch
bei 59 prozent
what you with the world of doctor
soliman des star trek universe star trek
youniverse war weniger wenn ich mein
komplettes leben in einem roulette spiel
hätte würde ich dann eher auf schwarz
auf rot setzen
ich meine wie soll ich da richtig liegen
also beim roulette spiel ist es so man
hat so eine platte und die dreht sich
man muss eine kugel rein schmeißt und da
wo sie liegen bleibt das ist alte rot
oder schwarz und einfaches noch grün
aber das steht hier halt nicht zur
auswahl ich würde einfach sagen rot und
bin weil sie
50 lokalen schwarz gedrückt weil der weg
geringer ist als links diese sache hier
ist ultra interessant und cool finde ich
und zwar würde ich lieber in einer stadt
wohnen die relativ weit weg ist und ich
die sprache deutlich kann oder auf einer
insel alleine
ich glaube er an einer stadt bin mir 68
prozent warum mache ich das hier wird
mal so komisch das was mit dem video
meine damen und herren es euch gefallen
hat drückt den daumen nach oben button
nicht ob das video wie die tage gesehen
haben
ich lasse es einfach mal wieder
hochfahren kulig schwer dann gefangen
ich wollte auch noch sagen dass ich euch
mag halt dein maul luca